la commune de dordives véritable désert
médical cette petite ville du loiret
devait ouvrir un cabinet médical
provisoire le 3 septembre dernier du
matériel fourni par la région
l'installation du système de télé
consultation est pourtant un cabinet
désespérément vide où l'indispensable
mon cas l'appel le médecin qui nous
accompagnait pour cette ouverture au
dernier moment pour des soucis je pense
avec l'ordre des médecins parce qu'il
avait un cabinet aussi ailleurs
en même temps le fait qu'on ait aussi
sur un projet pour 2022 d'une maison de
santé a dit ben voila je préfère
attendre la maison de santé vont devenir
alors d'endives avait une quinzaine
d'années trois médecins
il ya plus qu'un seul médecin libéral un
seul médecin à dordives difficile donc
pour les quelques trois mille trois
cents habitants d'avoir accès aux soins
dans les campagnes on n'a pas le droit
d'exister
savez 14 on peut plus se déplacer qu'on
est malade trouver tes bons médecins et
je déplace plus
bas et moi celui que j'ai parce que je
reparte après débat ça va être un gros
problème c'est pas trop facile mais il y
en a qui se dévouent pour essayer
d'assumer le peu de médecins qui a dans
la ville malheureusement les médecins
mais très vieillissant 1 qui disparaît
un autre qui ne le remplace pas donc je
pense que ce n'est fait maintenant que
pour la ville la campagne ça n'intéresse
plus les médecins mais c'est un gros
souci sur l'avenir on n'a pas un
packaging
important au niveau local médecin c'est
en voie de disparition face à cette
pénurie de médecins le maire de la
commune compte sur l'ouverture d'une
maison de santé prévue pour 2022 en
collaboration avec la région d'ici là
150 médecins doivent être recrutés et
répartis en centre val de loire dont 3
prévu pour la commune de dordives